[موسيقى]
بتقرير اللي نشرناه اليوم اللي هو مؤشر
التنويع الاقتصادي العالمي اللي حلل
الاقتصاديات لخمسه من الدول العالم بما
فيها الدول العربيه ودول المنطقه احتلت
دوله الامارات والسعوديه المرتبه الاول
والثاني على المستوى الخليجي وهذا طبعا
سببه انه هناك سياسات باخر عشر سنوات
عشرين عام في بعض الحالات اقل شوي كانت
مصممه للتنويع الاقتصادي منها استقطاب
المواهب ابقائها لفتره طويله الملكيه
الكامله للشركات الاجنبيه في مناطق
الفريزون وحتى خارج الفريزون التركيز على
الابتكار والتركيز على السياحه وكثير من
دعائم الاقتصاديه المتنوعه
ودوله الامارات والسعوديه الحقيقه نعم
تميزوا بهذا المج
[موسيقى]
مرات الحمد لله لم تتاثر بحتى بازم جوجل
بشكل كبير لانها كانت قنواتها مع الدول
المنتجه قنوات مفتوحه وكان لها
السمعه والعلاقه الطيبه القوه الناعمه
الكبيره اللي امنت الغذاء لها
بالنسبه للمستقبل بظل الحرب الاوكرانيه
وغيرها بغض النظر عن سبب او مصدر اي ازمه
التنوع الاقتصادي التنوع الاقتصادي لكل
دوله هو سر نجاح يعني لا تعتمد على مصدر
واحد او اثنين او ثلاثه من الدخل وانما
تعتمد على قاعده واسعه هذا التقرير
المخاطر بما فيها حتى الامن الع
[موسيقى]
بغض النظر عن التحالفات وكيف النظر لها
المستقبل ستقود التكنولوجيا وسيقود المعرف
وسيقود القطاع الشباب والمواهب وبالتالي
الدوله اي دوله والمنطقه ككل اذا اعتمدت
على هذا الامر لن يكون هناك داعي لاي من
هذه الامور سيكون الاقتصاد الاقتصاد معرفه
اقتصاد منتج ستفتح
الابواب امام التجاره الحره وهذا هو مفتاح
النجاح لاي منطقه واي اقليم